Này có thể bước quốc tình với đặc lập tự do, đảng ta đã có mức quá trình trình bị chú đáo,
kỹ lượng, kéo dài 1,5, kể tương ngày đam công sản Việt Nam được thành lập.
Tự chú chương, đường lối, đến xế vụ lực lượng chính trị, vụ trang, cân thứ điện cách mạng.
Đặc biệt, lượng nắm mắt và tận dụng thời cơ là yên tốt quan trọng làm linh tháng lợi cuộc cách mạng.
Thời cơ của cuộc tổng hình nghĩa chỉ kéo dài khoảng 2 tuần nế, tính từ khi nhật hoàn tên bố đầu hàng đồng mình,
đến lúc em ngốc các nước đi quốc trực dân được quan tài chính thục điện.
Một thay cơ thật lợi như vậy, lúc được mở ra không chỉ, cho Việt Nam đau không chỉ cho đông dương đau,
nếu mà ra cho tất cả các, các nước, các dân tộc trong khu vụ đồng mạng.
Thêm dừng mạ hú vụ đồng mạng chỉ có 2 nơi, tuyên bố được lập.
Đi lấy ở ít đồ điên xa ngày bị bệnh tháng và Việt Nam người chiến tháng tháng và đầu dành chiến quyền 1, 2, 3,
thì tuyên 1 được lập.
Thế thì như vậy thì có thể nói rằng là thời cơ thật lợi mà ra ngang bằng như nhau, cho các nước các dân tộc của đồng nắm.
Nhưng đau của phong trọng dân tộc mạng, đủ mạng thì đó người dân ở nước đó mới có thể dành được được lập.
Và thết lập được cái chính quyền dân tộc của mình.